right did we get it right Marie Dvorak
over there while you were making this
movie I've never thought of we've never
thought that we would be standing here
in this beautiful theater
so it's something overwhelming so I
would like to thank the Academy for this
award for inviting us here for this
incredible week that we have spent here
I will never forget it was incredible as
I was growing up I became worried a
little bit that I would lose the ability
to to play and the sense of wonder but
then I found it in movies and actually
in making movies and I was fortunate
enough that I was surrounded by people
like Martin that supported me and kept
encouraging me to play and to be created
without limitations so there is only two
of us here standing but there were many
many more people that helped me with
this movie and that made it possible for
me to make it there is more a little bit
like over 100 people that work on this
film so I'm not gonna be naming all of
them but I would like to just give them
big thank you big giant thank you to
everybody in New York at NYU I would
like to say giant thank you to Czech
Republic to everybody there I hope you
don't just carry publicy Stanier lucky
[Laughter]
without all of you I wouldn't have been
able to make this movie and I thank you
very much for being always on my side
and supporting me I'm very honored that
we could have worked on this together
thank you so much
[Applause]
let's